[Music]
foreign
[Music]
or maybe that's just me but what better
way to combine our two True Loves in
this world than watching movies about
food
chocolate lava cake is not just
undercooked chocolate cake that's not
what makes the center Molten
you take a frozen cylinder of ganache
and you set it in the Ramekin so that as
the outside Cooks fully the inside
becomes Molten that's right my friends
in preparation for the holidays and The
Delectable dishes that come with the
season we're going to be taking a look
at films that slice dice season bake
boil and simmer their way right through
our hearts and into our stomachs
so what you never use a recipe
everything I need is here here and here
for this list we're looking at Movies
centered around cooking and to be
included need at least 10 reviews and
are ranked highest by Tomato Meter so I
hope you have the appetite for a 10
course meal because we've cooked up our
list of the top 10 cooking movies of all
time
foreign
[Music]
number 10 soul food when Ahmad Simmons
is diabetic grandmother Josephine Big
Mama Joseph falls into a coma during an
operation to amputate her leg it throws
the Joseph Family into chaos Amad
watches as his mother Maxine and aunts
Terry and Tracy struggle to adjust to
the family matriarch's sudden absence
they fall into Old rivalries share
memories and work to maintain the
long-standing tradition of Sunday family
dinners starring Vanessa Williams Vivica
A fox Nia Long and directed by George
Tillman Jr critics say much like the
titular Cuisine soul food Blends a
series of savory ingredients to offer
warm generous helpings of nourishment
and comfort
what happened oh no
oh
I forgot
I left the top of my stove
oh my God
you all right oh just got it all on your
face he didn't mean done this is uh my
surprise everybody
Uncle Pete
I'm sorry man
[Music]
Big Mama really did have a pot of money
hitting away and she had a stash in the
last place we all think to look Uncle
Pete's TV
now I understand what soul food was all
about see during slavery as black folks
didn't have a whole lot to celebrate so
cooking became the way we expressed our
love for one another
number nine Like Water for Chocolate the
youngest daughter in her family the
beautiful Tita is forbidden to marry her
true love Pedro since tradition dictates
that Dita must care for her mother Pedro
Weds her older sister rosaura though he
still loves Tita the situation creates
much tension in the family and tita's
Powerful emotions begin to surface in
Fantastical ways through her cooking as
the years pass unusual circumstances
test the enduring love of Pedro and Tita
starring Lumi Cavazos Marco Leonardi
Regina tornay and directed by Alfonso
arau critics say Like Water for
Chocolate plays to the senses with a
richly rewarding romance that indulges
in magical realism to intoxicating
effect
is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
number eight chef after a controlling
owner pushes him too far Chef Carl
Casper quits his position at a
prestigious La restaurant and as he
tries to figure out what his next step
should be he finds himself in Miami Carl
joins forces with his ex-wife best
friend and son to launch a food truck
business and the Venture provides a
chance to reignite his passion for
cooking as well as his zest for life and
love starring Sophia Vergara John
Leguizamo and John Favreau who also
directed the film critics say Chef's
charming cast and sharp bunny script add
enough spice to make this feel-good
comedy a flavorful if familiar treat you
know about Twitter yeah
how does it work that's cool
it's cool that's how it works it's cool
you tweet on it it's not like texting no
sign me up
so what do you want your username to be
Carl
you can't just put Carl hold on I said
he had something
I'll call Casper
that's oral Casper
digging somebody took my name
[Applause]
at Chef curl Casper is that cool
at chef
Carl okay so is this for sex
ew how's everybody doing this for no I'm
not doing it for that so remember
something bad I want to see what they
wrote
good
hey
you can't talk like that I don't care if
mommy's not around I want you cursing
around here
that review went viral
what does that mean it means it got
picked up and retweeted everywhere so
all these people have read the review
yeah
number seven Eat Drink Man Woman Master
Chef shoe is semi-retired and he lives
at home with his three unmarried
daughters Gia Jen a religious chemistry
teacher Gia chian an airline executive
and Gian ning an employee at a fast food
joint life at the family's house
revolves heavily around preparing and
eating an elaborate dinner every Sunday
the stability of these meals gives him
all strength as they deal with the new
romantic relationships and
disappointments starring Leon xiong Hui
Mei Yang chian lien Wu Yuan Wang and
directed by Ang Lee critics say a richly
layered look at the complex interactions
between a widowed chef and his daughters
and Lee's generational comedy Eat Drink
Man Woman offers filmgoers a tasty
cinematic treat
foreign
[Music]
number six dinner rush one unlucky
evening Louis kropa part-time bookmaker
discovers that his restaurant has become
a hotbed of conflicting characters in
addition to having to please a whiny
food critic Louis must fend off a
hostile takeover from a pair of
gangsters to whom his sous chef is in
debt further Louis has an argument with
his son the star Chef whose culinary
creativity has brought success to the
business starring Danny a yellow Eduardo
ballerini Vivian Wu and directed by Bob
garaldi critics say with the aid of a
witty script and a well-acted Ensemble
dinner rush is a tasty dish
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't worry don't worry
it's the Romantic times they they always
do something special whenever whenever I
come here
another woman
I can't work like this man he's alive
number five mostly Martha Martha relies
on her culinary skills as her primary
means of communication she lives for her
work and presides with obsessive care
over her spotless precise kitchen when a
fateful accident leaves Lena her
eight-year-old niece in her care
Martha's orderly life begins to come
undone now when the owner is
consequently forced to bring in help
Martha and the new charming and carefree
Italian chef are instantly at odds
starring Martina gadek Sergio castellito
Maxime first and directed by Sandra
nettleback critics say mostly Martha may
have a predictable plot but it still
feels charming and fresh and the food
will make you hungry hours
foreign
foreign
[Music]
Ratatouille Remy a resident of Paris
appreciates good food and is quite a
sophisticated palette he would love to
become a chef so he can create and enjoy
culinary masterpieces to his heart's
Delight the only problem is Remy is a
rat and when he winds up in the sewer
beneath one of paris's finest
restaurants the rodent Gourmet finds
himself ideally placed to realize his
dream starring Patton Oswald Ian Holm
Lou romano and directed by Brad Berg
critics say fast-paced and stunningly
animated Ratatouille adds another
delightfully entertaining entry and a
rather unlikely hero to the Pixar Cannon
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number three big night
Chef Primo and businessman secundo are
immigrant Brothers From Italy who open
their dream restaurant Paradise in New
Jersey however Primo's authentic food is
too unfamiliar for the local tastes and
the restaurant is struggling when famous
Italian-American bandleader Louis Prima
is scheduled to appear at Paradise the
two brothers put all of their efforts
into the important meal which will
likely decide the fate of their
restaurant starring Minnie Driver Ian
Holm Isabella rosalini Tony Shalhoub and
Stanley Tucci who also directed the film
with Campbell Scott critics say the
performances in big night are wonderful
and the food looks delicious
foreign
okay
no wait cut off the table
okay okay
[Music]
we're just gonna be two out of school
no no we don't have time to do it let's
go come on come on Christian open the
door
[Music]
it's a secret recipe that they brought
from their homes
[Music]
oh my God number two the lunch box
lonely housewife Ila decides to try
adding some spice to her stale marriage
by preparing a special lunch for her
neglectful husband now unfortunately the
delivery goes astray and winds up in the
hands of sajan in irritable widower
curious about her husband's lack of
response Ela adds a note to the next
day's lunchbox and thus begins an
unusual friendship in which sajan and
Ela can talk about their Joys and
Sorrows without ever meeting in person
starring Irfan Kong nimrat Kaur
nawazuden Siddiqui and directed by
ritesh batra critics say warm
affectionate and sweet but not cloying
The Lunchbox is a clever crowd pleaser
from first time director ratesh batra
foreign
mere husband a favorite
evening
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions The Hundred Foot
Journey
Hassan kadam is an extraordinarily
talented and largely self-taught
culinary novice now when he and his
family are displaced from their native
India and settle in a quaint French
Village they decide to open an Indian
Eatery however Madame Mallory the
proprietress of an acclaimed restaurant
just 100 feet away strongly objects War
erupts between the two establishments
until Mallory recognizes kadam's
impressive Epicurean gifts and takes him
under her Wing starring Dame Helen Marin
on Puri Manesh Dayal and directed by
lass halstrom critics say director last
halstrom does lovely work and Helen
Mirren is always worth watching but the
100 foot journey travels predictable
ground already covered by countless
feel-good dramedies
too much
Beauty
holidays
espanol and Bejamin
[Music]
um you know Madame Malory says
that she knows in just one mouthful if a
chef has the potential to be great
today's special
a young Manhattan Chef rediscovers his
passion for life by making Indian food
starring Dean Winters Kevin Corrigan
Asif mandvi and directed by David Kaplan
Rob Thomas from Capital time says
sometimes you'll want a meal that tastes
exactly like you expect it's gonna taste
today's special is one of those meals
here come on you try it me yeah of
course you who else no no I don't walk
like that well come on give it a try my
friend come on
come on
I don't even know the proportions
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
job New Yorker Julie Powell embarks on a
daring project she vows to prepare all
524 recipes in Julia Child's Landmark
cookbook mastering the art of French
cooking intertwine with Julie's story is
the true tale of how Julia Child herself
conquered French cuisine with passion
fearlessness and plenty of butter
starring Meryl Streep Amy Adams Stanley
Tucci and directed by Nora Ephron
critics say boosted by Meryl Streep's
charismatic performance is Julia Child
Julie and Julia is a light but fairly
entertaining culinary comedy
which is
bonjour
madame
[Applause]
Madam listen
you must hold the knife first of all
like this race easy
the hand and the knife are one and the
Hand the other hand you must protect it
yeah you must cut only the onion yes not
me
and then you put your thumb here and the
other finger is here we
go
you're being a little over competitive
don't you think well you should have
seen the way those men looked at me
as if I was some frivolous housewife
just looking for a way to kill time
and finally number one tampopo the tale
of an eccentric band of culinary Ronin
who guide the Widow of a noodle shop
owner on her quest for the perfect
recipe interspersing the efforts of
tampopo and friends to make her Cafe a
success with the erotic exploits of a
gastronome gangster and glimpses of food
culture both high and low the sweet sexy
and surreal tampopo is a lavishly
inclusive pan to the sensual joys of
nourishment and one of the most
mouth-watering examples of food on film
ever made starring sutomu yamazaki
nobuko Miyamoto kenwada Nabi and
directed by juzo Itami critics say
thanks to director zuzoe Tommy's offbeat
humor and sharp satirical Edge tampopo
is a funny sexy affectionate celebration
of food and its broad influence on
Japanese culture
foreign
[Music]
yes
well my friend said about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and until
next time I am your host Naz Perez and I
am starving but we'll see you back here
for more top tens on the Rotten Tomatoes
countdown
foreign
[Music]